yeah we're sitting here talking about
Steven Seagal still again and we can't
like I said we've like I've been reading
all kind of different [ __ ] like this
morning about because we're gonna like
record the show later about him yeah so
I don't want to like ruin all the best I
run down store go get some candy food
oh no we're on a kiddin bit and bacon
bacon powder I tried to bake some
biscuits last night and it did they
didn't rise they were all [ __ ] up
looking and I checked the bacon powder
man it was [ __ ] 2004 Best Buy yeah
yeah I just was like [ __ ] heads I
hadn't even met you then we had yeah we
had I had you know we had several cans
of it you know me but one of those that
somehow through the mousse and you know
moving from one place to another you
know we just one of those things that's
2004 that's hilarious
yeah and I think that's why I did Rob no
wonder well because the same thing have
okay so this is what happened for some
reason like - it was two nights ago
right you kind of like got this be in
your Ronnie's like man we should make
some business and I was like hey that
sounds like a good idea it's make a
bunch of biscuits because you can make
breakfast and all this weird [ __ ] we
have this big thing of Bisquick which I
don't even think was opened and it was
like yeah pantry it had been opened
could be yeah so like they didn't rise
and they came out really bad I said Best
Buy 2014 yeah it was super and I was
like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and so then like the next day he's gonna
make another batch and they looked good
like it left them and they like septum
using like a glass it's like huh turn
[ __ ] cutting them open and they're
doing like that so that should be
[ __ ] fantastic they didn't rise I
didn't know maybe if the cookie cutter
somehow sealed the edges and at dinner I
don't and I just checked checked my
[ __ ] ingredients in that damn baking
powder maybe that's not a 2004 they
still tasted good though I'm you so
because today he made like last night he
just like fried some eggs and cheese and
put him on there so we ate we ate him
anyway and then today he made be like
biscuits and gravy ah yeah
I didn't have any was good didn't mean I
didn't have any pork sausage so I just
thought out a couple of pork chops and
just chopped them by hand oh is that how
you did that yeah I didn't see him maybe
I tried to make some ground pork out of
it and then I seasoned it like it was
sausage you know that's good that's
pretty good I have fried that up and
then you know made country gravy black
pepper yeah baby yeah your southern
southern [ __ ] man it's just butter and
flour
I know salt I hope you know ground
[ __ ] black pepper in it and a little
bit of seasoned salt cream but that's
the thing it's like well yeah but it's
like the the nice thing about it is that
it's so filling that I probably won't
want ya until later that's probably
ninety thousand calories sure probably
was which means that I can't eat any
more I got a lift tonight yeah well I at
least I got in I got in a three-mile
walk today so okay that's like so what's
not a talk about not uh not a whole lot
honestly cuz like I said all I've been
doing today was like research in the
Steven Seagal show that we're gonna do
and like you know [ __ ] like that
um I get some juice so we can [ __ ]
drink yeah apple juice right yeah I
gotta get orange juice yeah I kind of
feel like I mean the Steven Seagal show
it's like like I said he he kind of he's
terrible person but like in a way that's
ridiculous and like funny to laugh at I
don't know
so it should be funny uh I like Steven
Seagal I think he's an amazing man I
hope he sees this but so much so much
has been said about him he's price sick
of hearing it see now in the United
States our seat or seat I think he's
wanted here and he um well no because I
think he got he got charged I'm gonna
try the sec oh that [ __ ] all got dropped
yes so that all got dropped yeah there
have been like numerous sexual assault
allegations and stuff like that but I
don't know if any of those are still
pending because a lot of those he
settled them out of court yeah uh-huh so
so if he tries to [ __ ] shiatsu on
your boobs looking for [ __ ] cancer
lumps and [ __ ] just run away cuz he
won't believe you
the cats just least you know you're
gonna get a paycheck cuz you know get a
lawyer and then you'll get he'll break
you off because he doesn't want anybody
even though everybody knows they he's a
total and the complete creep and like to
stay away from him beating up on little
guys you'd beaten up on everybody
beating up on his wife beating up one
[ __ ] he's a terrible person I'm
telling you but yeah so other than that
what were we just now this was kind of
an interesting conversation that we had
right before we started recording I
probably should have started recording
earlier so we could have got some of it
but we were wondering cuz you were
asking me if I could tell the difference
between a male writer and a female right
yeah if you're reading story if you're
reading a story yeah um and I was saying
cuz you you were talking about somebody
that you were watching that was talking
about he said that he saw he said that
the difference the difference between
the way little boys and little girls
grow up and where they play with toys
that that affects how they write a story
later on that the females tend to inject
themselves into the into the females of
the story and that men tend to be more
distended detached from it they're not
really injected into the story which
that might be true up to a point but I
did tell him I was like you know I have
like tons of you know anthologies you
know usually horror stories or fantasy
or something like that and a lot of
times I'll just like just glance at the
title or not even glance at the title
and then I'll just read the story and
I'm like if you you know said hey I'll
give you $1,000 if you can tell me if a
man or a woman wrote that I would not be
really no I can't I can't claim to be
able to tell the difference but I don't
think I can sometimes tell a difference
in a movie um sometimes it's like I said
I think it depends on the genre it
honestly it kind of comes down to the
individual because and I was telling you
this before and I can't remember who
this was but it was kind of like one of
the one of the better-known maybe like
action thriller dude writers and I
remember reading something of his and
going oh well obviously a man wrote that
but because he was trying to write from
a female characters perspective and it
was like clear that he didn't know how
to write from a female characters
perspective um so but other than that I
really don't
if it's a good writer and you can become
immersed in their writing and you can
become immersed in the characters I
can't really tell a difference I think
it's only when the writing is shitty or
you know I don't know it's it's just
hard for me to I can tell I can tell
Quentin Tarantino that that's a man that
those that those movies well obviously
very obvious but then I could take it
he's real a little brow but that's what
he's trying to do but then I could take
it to Stanley Kubrick and I can
definitely tell that's a man right
telling that story yeah especially like
some of the older stuff how clinical it
is yeah yeah I mean like 2001 feels very
clinical very clear Oliver like that but
there's something very masculine about
them though there's something and
they're in shining it's very cold but
it's also kind of very masculine I think
it's part of that clinical detached
feeling you get when you're watching the
damn thing yeah maybe even dr.
Strangelove which was a comedy [ __ ]
awesome they're still kind of had this
weird detached kinda third-person
although I don't know if that's even so
much that's just his style so I would
think that's more like an individual's
and the same thing with Quentin
Tarantino he has a very obvious style
but I'm saying that that I'm saying that
that that relates to alright it's just
the way I'm seeing it you know I'm
saying Kubrick's style to me feels very
masculine you know another thing too is
that sometimes I'll be surprised like
I'll see a horror movie or something
like that and then I'll find out later
that a woman directed it and it
surprised me that it won't be directed
it not just not because I mean a lot of
women don't direct horror movies sadly
but just because it didn't really occur
to me yeah I guess is it it doesn't
really stand out as being gendered in
one way or another I think like I said
it's it's kind of anything like that
it's just kind of like a continuum it's
like obviously there's gonna be some
really obvious [ __ ] that's like
obviously a man directed that are
obviously a man wrote that or obviously
a woman wrote that but I don't know in a
lot of ways like I said if it's good
writing I don't think you can really
tell yeah so if you can tell that means
it's a sign of you you can't write not
necessarily I mean it might just be a
particular style or
particular genre like I said it's really
kind of hard to say across the board
I've just really never had I've never
had a situation where where I was like
oh obviously you know a woman wrote that
or obviously you know what I mean um
although like I said I have had
situations where I saw a movie and then
later I found it out it found out that a
woman during our romance novels that
women like to read are they better if
they're written by a man or they're
better that they're written by a woman I
can't you know what I can't really say
because I'm not a big fan of romance
novels and never have been
um even you know even when I was a kid I
just I don't know I just didn't like
them they just seem very are they mostly
people and men um I probably mostly
written by women aren't they I would
imagine that it might be I think a lot
of them are written by men but I think
romance might be slightly more
represented by women
okay I don't know the statistics out
about right the thing about it though is
that sometimes particularly your like
your pulp romance sounds like the
paperbacks and stuff like that they put
out cheap one thing that a lot of the
publishing houses will do is they'll
have like a set number of like you know
names for that publishing company but a
bunch of different writers right under
that name some of them are men some of
them are women but they're all writing
under this particular pseudonym yeah so
so I don't really know it's really hard
to tell it in a lot of ways it's it
might be hard to tell you know even in
that genre if it was written by a man or
a woman because you know you because it
even if it's under a woman's name say
that doesn't necessarily mean that a
woman wrote it that might just be one of
the house names for that publication and
I'm talking here I'm not talking about
like you're kind of bigger known writers
I'm talking about like you're kind of
you know you're paperback ones like you
find in the back of the library or
whatever that just kind of come out
cheap and everything it was the same
thing with like westerns any kind of you
know it's probably changed a lot now
because the publishing and industry
isn't quite the same as it used to be a
lot of its gone well it's just it's
shifted online is more self-publishing
stuff like that but back in the days
when they had like these cheap pulp
paperbacks and they had like your cheap
romance when she had a cheap westerns
yeah a cheap sci-fi you know you guys
kind of stuff you guys have you guys
you know Millennials and everything you
should have seen what it was like back
when we were growing up when you were in
the damn grocery store during the
checkout you would see the damn little
what he called his little racks as
little yeah rotating rotating book racks
I'm doing this people like they were
these tall books in there in a wire and
it would spin and that was the only
thing that was there in the supermarket
pretty much you know they had spies [ __ ]
and stuff but the media the main state
you have Stephen King stuff yeah but
then the main staple was [ __ ] romance
novels which were porn for women and
westerns [ __ ] ton of westerns those were
the main two because those are like the
largest selling yeah in that you know
demographic attack covers were all the
same pretty all look different but they
were all the same you if you see him you
know exactly what I'm talking about well
how do you think [ __ ] Fabio got
famous it was like a model for a lot of
those for a mass novel cover yes they
just put them in different outfits yeah
he's just different outfits and it's
just like painting doing different but
it's interesting now though I feel like
in a way it's a lot better cuz you know
now it's easier for people to publish
their own [ __ ] which you know obviously
that's a lot of crap but to be honest a
lot of stuff that was published by
mainstream publishers was kind of crap
that I do too
but without rat machine yeah it's like
you know yeah a lot of the self
publishers like need some editors and
[ __ ] like that and but there's a lot of
good [ __ ] out there now something that
women do write a lot to no matter what
light write a lot to I guess depending
on what but women read a lot of erotica
yeah you know I mean I feel like well
then they buy most of the written
erotica that you know that's paid for I
remember reading somewhere and you know
it might be different now but I think
between 70 and 80% of the written
erotica that has been sold was purchased
by women yeah because and I think I may
have written by Chuck tangle yeah
seriously if you guys don't know who
Chuck tangle is I go check that [ __ ]
please go see please go check out Chuck
tangle Oh [ __ ] Salieri's oh my
god is he the best names the name the
name of the [ __ ] book is pounded in
the butt by my own butt right that was
our pee
whoa okay in a but by my book about my
own button now see numbers seriously
good at his Wikipedia page and it has
like a horn and it's [ __ ] weird
it's so [ __ ] funny and it's like and
and his it's funny because like gay well
not all of it though is that but then
like he has like a whole sub shot he has
like a whole thing about um you know
airplanes having sex with airplanes or
something there's like a whole dinosaur
yeah there's just oh my god yeah there's
go there's a whole ghost is there
Bigfoot okay so he has like all these
different kind of things yeah and like
they're just I I really want to buy what
I like read the whole thing but it's
like I've read excerpts and it's just
like I was just left yeah it's funny the
titles would be like powdered in the
rear by my billionaire airplane
boyfriend yeah I think that one
something like that yeah his boyfriend
is an airplane and the airplane is a
billionaire yeah and like Barbara Scott
it's good it's got like a muscle man on
there like Fabio and he's like blowing
kisses towards a [ __ ] airplane and
then superimposed into the bottom of the
fuselage as an airplane it's like a
smiling face
it's so [ __ ] hilarious
well I'm trying to remember like this
cuz I can't remember if the first
iteration of the book was called was
just called pounded in the butt I think
it was called but ception no no that was
a later one because he either had one
either the first one was called Pat just
powdered in the butt powdered in about
yeah and then he had pounded in the butt
by my own butt yeah yeah and then he had
yeah nothing in the butt by my book
countered in the butt by my own but his
own book and then like five or six in it
was but ception perception yeah it's not
serious
no Bob is all calm and he another thing
he does too is that he will write
something based around like you know
whatever is like real of the moment like
you remembered like this is probably
this a couple years ago but remember
that whole thing about that dress and
like is it black or blue black and blue
or is it
origin wherever that the [ __ ] it was and
it was like this huge sensation and it's
like he always like adds that in so like
the keywords like one of his books will
come up with the keywords so it's like
pounded in the butt by my own butt and
in the color changing dress and stuff
like that in there making concepts a
sexual [ __ ] op yeah in the book it's
[ __ ] weird and the funny thing about
him though is that obviously Chuck
tingle is not his real name but he will
not let anybody like he doesn't have
like a bio of himself he doesn't he
doesn't show his dog photos like a
drawing of him or something like that I
think there's only like one interview
with him and the answers he gave were
just like these non sequiturs answer
yeah so it's like no one knows who he is
I don't think I think the only real
photograph he ever showed was a stock
photograph of a dude in a kung fu gear I
think so yeah and maybe a drawing I
think I remember seeing a drawing there
was supposed to be like his driver's
license yes we're just trying to spread
some by culture to our listeners here do
you need to go check out [ __ ] Chuck
dangle that's a cultural experience I
mean yeah like even just read his books
but even just reading the Wikipedia page
just reading all the title just reading
the titles it will just give you hours
of entertainment you know what I mean I
think I think he books and I like
[ __ ] 99 cents or a dollar they're
sure they're like short stories it's
it's not like he's right in an Idaho
books every day because he's written and
everyone would me and the unicorn
colonel or what is those unicorns I'm
not you know I guess a unicorn there's a
whole unicorn line and like the unicorn
colonel was is like a unicorn who is
dressed as a colonel who is on the back
of a horse yeah in a like Civil War
outfit right yeah something like that
the unicorn colonel and and the you
think there's a hole I forgot what the
unit with what what the unicorn colonel
was in the title I know I can't remember
like did to look up the Wikipedia like
goes to the unicorn colonel
yeah ghosts and unicorns having sex
human beings and airplanes it's great
yeah
another dinosaurs on the there was done
a set weird sex dinosaurs and yeah with
ghosts and [ __ ] yeah I'm pretty sure
those aliens and maybe Bigfoot there's
like a lot of like crossovers between
like different cryptids and whatnot and
yeah it's funny because I mean I don't
you know I've written a couple of like
you know erotica stories and stuff like
that but it's like it's not really a
genre that I read a lot of you know so
much I guess but the market at the right
way yeah but the thing about it is that
I mean especially nowadays now that
everybody's kind of like writing all
their own [ __ ] and everything
um there's like a staggering array of
different genres and subgenres that you
wouldn't even unless you were into it
and each one has their like enthusiastic
proponents like that right and people
read them and stuff like that like
thousands and thousands of people but
it's like the mainstream is never really
like heard about it you know what I mean
I mean most people nowadays are probably
heard of like vore where you know you
want to be eaten by another person or
not so much that you want to be eaten
like like a cannibal or anything but
that you're like really small and you
want to be eaten by like Godzilla
there's that type of thing you know
there's a whole male pregnancy thing
that's a whole genre way of pregnant
with subgenres in its own thing so
that's a whole thing there's a you know
there's less weird ones like you have a
whole subset of like Viking romance and
all that kind of stuff but it is like
there's all kind of one of the most
popular is not it's not really
bestiality but it's kind of like having
sex with like a shape change like a
werewolf or something like that that's
like a humongous like some moves of
where bears yeah yeah so you know it's
just like furries really kinda all about
yeah that's right kind of like a
different thing though I think most of
the written erotica that's I can't even
remember what the name of because they
all have like names for the subgenres
but um but it's usually like essentially
a werewolf it's not
it's not necessarily a wolf but it's
usually like a person that can change it
to like some big powerful animal and
people are into it or whatever but you
know whatever no judgement is there
anything else I don't think so like I
said it's Friday Tom's got a mic a
supply run cuz yeah kitties are out of
food we don't put my space suit on you
had to put your space suit on your has
matter simple like the [ __ ]
terminator yeah put your glasses in your
boots on yeah no I can do it my dress up
like that for the show okay funny
because like well it's like you know is
Steven Seagal he's action here you know
terminators yeah be the Terminator it
works okay all right so I'll talk to you
guys against the park stay safe out
there